[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADAM RODRIGUEZ: Hi everyone.
Welcome to this talk
on Android Things.
Glad you're still with us.
I'm Adam.
I'm a product manager
here at Google.
AMY JANG: And I'm Amy.
I lead engineering for
Android Things Console.
ADAM RODRIGUEZ: And
today we're going
to talk to you about how to
use the Android Things console
to update your production
devices in the field.
As you hopefully learned
from a few other talks at IO,
Android Things is
a great platform
for building yourself some IoT.
But when it comes to
actually making more than one
of something, how
do you maintain
that device over its lifetime?
How do you support those
devices once they're
in customer's hands?
That's what we're here to
talk to you about today.
OK.
So let's do a
really quick review
of what is Android Things
and why you might want it.
First of all, it has
the power of Android.
Developed with the same
tools that you know and love,
if you're an Android
developer, this
is easy, because this
is Android after all.
Secondly, it scales from
prototype to production.
You don't need to be a hardware
engineer or a firmware engineer
to do this.
We provide fully certified SoMs.
Android Things isn't AOSP, so
to use the stuff that we're
talking about in
this talk you need
to use Android Things SoMs.
The advantage here
is that these SoMs
are built for the platform.
So you just need to
write Android code.
You don't need to worry
about low level firmware
to drive that hardware.
And finally, with automatic
updates, security is built in.
Because you're developing
on certified SoMs,
it allows Google to manage
the security of your device.
Google provides updates
and security fixes
that you can implement
throughout the lifetime
of your product.
Our goal with Android Things
is to make things easy for you.
Easy, managed and secure.
But this does raise
the question--
why is IoT so hard?
Do I really need to
worry about this?
So think a little
bit about what it
would take for you to ship
a few thousand managed,
secure IoT devices.
You're going to have to do
the hard stuff of building
the devices, designing the
hardware, writing the software.
It's hard, but it's
also the special sauce
that makes your device unique.
But beyond that, there's
a ton of other stuff
you need to do too.
How do you share development
with other engineers?
If you want your
devices to be secure,
you have to keep up to date
with latest security patches.
Once you've found
those patches, you
have to build a way for your
devices to get those patches.
And then how do you
update them in a safe way?
If the update goes
bad, how do you
make sure you don't break
your customers' devices?
Imagine designing delta updates,
fractional rollouts, A/B
partitions, channel management.
All these things you
need for successful IoT.
But maintaining and updating
all that infrastructure
is a massive job.
So like we said
earlier, our goal
is to make it easier for
you with Android Things.
So the hardware and the software
design, it's still up to you--
like it should be.
It's what makes your
product special.
But we make it
easier because you
can use all your familiar
tools such as Android Studio
and [INAUDIBLE] to do it.
But you don't need to bother
with firmware code because
of the Android Things
managed SoMs model.
Then when it comes
to security updates,
you get to leverage the
entire Android team here
to find and fix security holes.
Plus with automatic
updates, you get
those security patches
with literally zero
involvement from
you, years after you
ship your last device.
And for updates, we're
leveraging the same technology
used to update millions of
devices in the field every day.
Hardened, proven and optimized.
So you can focus on the part
that actually differentiates
your product--
the features and
applications that you write.
AMY JANG: So let's
walk through an example
to see how Android Things
will help you do that.
Imagine that Adam and I are
building a laundry folding
robot, because, let's be honest,
nobody loves folding socks,
right?
So this robot uses lots of
object recognition, vision
machine learning,
which is a perfect use
case for Android Things.
How do I take that
from a prototype
that I just build at home and
make it available for everyone?
This is where the magic
of our console comes in.
Android Things has it been
designed intentionally
to make it easy for
you to develop hardware
and ship it to the market.
And you can use
Android Things console
to take care of all your needs.
First thing configure-- you
will define a device management
group which we call
products, and by uploading
apps you have written using
editors like Android Studio,
you can manage your apps
using [INAUDIBLE] console.
And using build
functionality, you
can create secure Android
Things images with the apps
that you just wrote,
and at release step,
you can push seamless
updates to your devices
and use analytics to make
sure that your release went
smoothly.
So let's dig into details
of how all this works.
ADAM RODRIGUEZ: OK.
So the first step in this road
from prototype to production
is to set up some details in
the console of the product
that you plan to build.
Let's configure
our laundry robot.
First off, set up your product
name and create models.
Let's imagine we had
a few different SKUs.
Maybe we've got a
UK SKU and US SKU.
Models let you break
out your product
into different versions.
You next want to
pick your SoM type.
Pick a SoM based on the
features you need and the price
point you wish to hit.
Picking a SoM is
important because it
controls a lot about the image
that you want to create later.
One note though.
If you start building with one
SoM and then want to change it,
it's really easy without having
to rewrite a lot of code.
It's one of the things
that I personally really
love about our
managed SoM model.
You can start with
something really expensive
and then downgrade once you
want to cut costs at production.
Or you can hack together
something really cheap,
and then if the performance
doesn't meet your needs,
you can upgrade to
a more powerful SoM.
Finally, set up
product sharing too.
Since Amy and I are building
this laundroid together,
we share access to this
product via the console,
so either one of us can
upload apps and create builds.
Once you get the
product configured,
the next step is
to write your apps.
Apps are the core of
Android, and Android Things
is no exception.
They define all the
functionality inside
of Android Things.
When Amy wrote the
feature for folding socks,
she did that in [INAUDIBLE] APK.
You can use all the tools you're
familiar with as an Android
developer--
Android Studio, Kotlin, Google
Play services, Firebase.
It all just works
because, again, this
is just Android after all.
Once your apps are written, you
upload them to the app library.
So you can add them into builds.
As you can see here, we've
got four different apps
that break out our laundry
robot's functionality.
The app library also
takes care of versioning,
so when you've got a
new version of your app,
the library takes care to
show you the most recent one.
One piece that I really love
about this is app sharing.
Just like you can share a
product with a collaborator,
you can share apps too.
Android itself is all
about building apps
that others can use
and Android Things
is no exception here either.
So share your aps
with other people
on your team or other people
building similar products.
While today, you're
probably only going
to use apps that you wrote
yourself, as more people build
on Android Things, you might
find yourself using apps
that other people wrote for
utilities and common features.
AMY JANG: And now it's
time to build images
with Android Things apps
that you guys wrote.
In our case I wrote
a brand new socks.APK
to give our robot some awesome
new sock folding functionality.
Adam just uploaded
to the app library
in console, also shared with me.
So now that we have
added this functionality,
it's time to
package it up into a
build and flash
onto your devices.
So Build is where all the
ingredients come together.
Apps, Google Apps,
hardware configurations
that you may want to
customize for your device.
The set of options that
you have chosen here
are what we call
build configurations.
And build configurations are
like secret sauces and rules
and configurations that specify
the content of the device
image.
And by device image,
I mean the images
to flash to your devices,
and images to create payloads
for over the air update.
So in this Build step, you
can create new and many
build configurations
and manage them.
For most of you, you
will have just bought
or received from this
I/O the developer kit.
To get started, you can select
the Use Starter Kit settings,
and all the build details
will be pre-populated for you.
For this example though,
let's walk through an example
of starting from scratch.
First, one of the
most important things
is to select like your
Android Things OS version.
Pick the newest
version that you're
comfortable with because
those will have the latest bug
fixes and security updates.
You're not forced to
use the latest one.
But it's recommended
for this reason.
Next up, in this step, you
will see the list of apps
that you have uploaded
in the app library.
Select the apps that you want
to include into your build.
And don't forget to include
the apps provided by Google
like Google Play services.
And why would you want
Google Play services?
With Google Play
services, your apps
can take advantage of the latest
Google API, such as Nearby,
Maps, Firebase, including
the new [INAUDIBLE] kit
included in the Google
Play service package.
Simply click on the checkbox
you saw in the dialog
and it will be
included in your build.
ADAM RODRIGUEZ: OK.
So back to the build.
Once you select your
apps, take a look
at the permissions those
apps are requesting
and make sure that
you're OK with them.
Since your users can't
opt into permissions
themselves like with regular
Android, it's up to you
to do it for them.
If you're only using apps that
you've developed yourself,
there really shouldn't
be any surprises here.
But if you're using
apps shared from others,
it's worth taking a look.
This is helpful to prevent the
doing something wrong that you
weren't expecting, and
a good security measure.
As Android Things
gets more common,
it won't be all that surprising
to see other people building
IoT products with shared
apps from various sources.
So looking at
permissions is important.
The next step is all
about adding additional
build resources to your build.
If your device
has a display, you
can add a boot animation
as you see here
for the Lenovo smart display.
You can upload your own
custom bootanimation.zip.
Also in this section,
we let you choose
if you want to include fonts.
Since a lot of these
devices won't have displays,
we don't want to
burden them with fonts.
It's all about reducing the
image size for these small IoT
products.
Now, your Android Things device
wouldn't be very interesting
if it was just the SoM.
Hardware config is where
you add your peripherals,
control your GPIOs
and bus speeds.
Starter kits are pre-set
up with the default
hardware configs which you
provide in the starter kit
build.
However, you might want to
spice up your configurations
differently.
You can use this UI
tool to adjust it.
While this tool is currently
limited to controlling bus
speed and pullup resistors,
this is where in the future
you're going to configure
all of your peripherals,
such as cameras, displays,
audio buses and speakers.
We also plan to give you
control over your I/O here,
so you can do pin boxing,
and determine which pins are
attached to which functions.
So keep an eye on this
space for more updates soon.
AMY JANG: So here you are
at your final build step.
You will see that the
configurations you made
are displayed with
their total estimated
sizes under OEM partition.
Review the estimate
size in summary
and set the total size of
OEM partition as you like.
You may wonder, what
are these partitions,
and can I, as a
developer, change?
And which partitions are
update-able with over the air
update?
To answer that, lets look at the
Android Things partition layout
for a moment.
On the left is the simple
partition layout of IMX7D PICO.
That's the board that you
got from the developer kit.
There are small differences
between the SOC vendors
and boards.
But let's walk
through an example
of partitions that are used
by the core Android Things
architecture, which is
the same across all SoMs.
Starting with system, system and
boot are read only partitions,
and it's generated for and
used for the Android Things
platform.
Boot is for kernel and the
ramdisk for the normal boot.
And system is where Android
Things OS is loaded.
Vbmeta is a read-only partition.
And it's used for
verified boot mechanism.
As the name suggests,
this is where
metadata for your verified
boot is written to.
Specifically, it's a single
hash generated by Google
using information of
boot, system and vendor,
and signed with a secure
key stored in Google.
For every boot
sequence of a device,
bootloader verifies that
the code is authentic
and no known security
flaw has been
found using this information.
Devices will not boot if any
tampering has been found.
So you don't want to mess
around with this partition.
Vendor is a read only
partition as well.
In this partition, the
binary image from SOC vendors
are loaded.
Things like driver
libraries specific to SOC
are usually put in here.
OEM and the OEM bootloader are
partitions for Android Things
developers, and that's you.
It's read only in a sense that
after it's been generated,
it cannot be tampered with
for the security reason I just
talked about.
But OEM is a partition
where the contents
of the build configuration that
you specified through console
is written to.
So in that sense,
it is rewritable
and managed by Android Things
developers through a console.
This OEM partition
is also generated new
when you're creating the new
build from configuration 4
to OTA.
And OEM bootloader
is a partition
where the hardware configuration
you might have chosen
that build is written too.
If you're an Android
developer, you
may be familiar with this
partition, user data.
This is where systems and
apps will write their user
data at runtime.
Aside from that, APKs that you
install through ADB install,
or the play button
in Android Studio
are also written
into this partition.
So this poses
actually a question.
Package Name is a unique
identifier of an app.
If the same package name exists
both in user data and OEM,
how would Android
Package Manager
know which app to be used?
OEM is read only after
it's been generated.
So the APKs that are
already written there
should still exist as is.
When you're
developing, and you're
most likely going to be changing
your APKs via ADB install.
To honor this
development flow, the ADB
installed APKs in
user data is always
honored over the ones in OEM.
So what this means
is, if you have APKs
both in user data
and OEM, you want
the APK loaded an
OEM to work, you
will simply delete
the APK in user data
by ADB on the install.
Misc is another read-only
partition used by platform.
It's for miscellaneous
needs like bootloader
and our system for
its functionalities.
Factory and its
bootloader partition
is reserved for any
per-device configurations,
like serial number, to
be written at factories.
This can also be done
later in service centers.
This partition is writable
by developers and factory,
and it's going to be read
only after it's being shipped.
So writing to this
partition requires
special tools and authorities,
which we will provide for you.
So up to now, we've gone
over all the partition
that Android Things
core architecture uses.
You might have noticed the
partition in this table
are duplicated in two
sections, a and b.
What do those mean?
This is where the OTA over
the air update comes in.
OTA works by AB
partition mechanism,
where the same partition kind
exists in two duplicate memory
spaces.
This architecture provides a
seamless update to users where
devices can still be active
with an active partition
where the updates are being
downloaded and installed
onto the inactive partition A
B. So after all that's done,
after the rebooting with
a secure boot mechanism,
devices will wake
up to the partition
where the update has
been installed onto.
It's also important to note that
all read-only Android Things
partitions is fixed
at a certain size.
And as you know, the board
memory is also fixed.
What this means is that
there is a remaining fixed
memory to be split between
OEM partition and userdata
partition.
And you'll decide what the
split will be between the two.
So let's walk
through an example.
So say you have chosen
LTS OS, a couple apps,
Google Play services, maybe
custom hardware configuration.
In this console
[INAUDIBLE] view,
which you saw at the
final build step,
we took away all the
nitty gritty details
of the system partitions
that you have seen so far.
So if you haven't been paying
attention in the last slides,
it's OK.
All you need to know is
that the system partition
is a fixed size.
So the OEM partition size
input, we ask you to input
is going to be a size of
a single OEM partition.
So what this means is, when you
increase the size of the OEM
partition by 100, the
user data partition
will be subtracted by 200.
So here is the most important
message about partition
you should take
away from this talk.
Choosing the right
OEM partition size
is important when you're
making production images.
When devices are baked
with the chosen size,
they are fixed in
the size layout
until they are reflashed.
This is because of the nature
of AB and the OTA mechanism
we just talked about.
So these devices only
receive OTA updates
to build with the
same partition size.
One recommendation though
when setting the size
is to leave some buffer
room for future growth.
You may want to add new
functionality to your APK,
you may want to add more, like
a new cool boot animation,
which may require more memory.
So plan for the
future and estimate
how much you might want between
apps growth versus the data
growth.
Again, you don't
have to plan it yet.
When you're at prototyping
and development phase,
you don't have to worry
about finding the right size.
Because you can always
reflash the device.
You just need to estimate
and finalize this
when you're making
production images.
You've now chosen the right
size, created the build,
and with create a
build configuration,
you can choose between
two image options--
development and production.
Development builds provide
debugging capabilities
like ADB, and
production builds are
to be secure and
used by end users.
It doesn't provide debugging.
Note that once devices are
flashed with production images,
it cannot be tampered
for security reasons.
So it needs to be recovered in
order to make it a debuggable.
When you click on Download,
the image will be generated
and the download will
start through the browser.
And now you have
downloaded the image file.
How do I take that from
the file to my devices?
We provide a Flash script
tool to make this all super
simple and easy for you.
Simply navigate to
the tool section
and download the script.
Follow the instruction
in the script
and it should be all
pretty straightforward
and your devices
will be ready to go.
You can also use fast
boot instead of the script
if you so wish.
So with that, we're finished
building, downloading
and preparing an
Android Things device.
ADAM RODRIGUEZ: Right.
So up until this point,
it's been all about building
functionality into your
Android Things device.
And while Android Things
makes development easy,
you probably could have
done the same thing
with a bunch of other
platforms out there.
But release is where things
get really different.
Updating, supporting,
pushing new features,
not just to your devices,
but to thousands of devices
in the field.
This is where Android Things
really starts to shine.
I like to say that
there's two reasons why
you might choose Android
Things as an operating system.
One, you love the
power of Android,
you're comfortable with
it, familiar with it.
Or two, you plan to make
more than one of something.
Amy and I have
this laundry robot.
She has this laundry robot
that knows how to fold socks.
But my laundry robot at my house
doesn't know how to fold socks.
How do we get that build that
she's running onto my robot?
With Android Things
it's super easy.
First off, use channels to
break up your device population.
You might have a few
devices owned by customers,
a few others owned by testers.
And you don't want them all
getting the same builds.
So put them on channels so you
can segment them logically.
You can also create custom
channels, say a QA channel,
or a channel for people
who like the color blue
to further divide things.
With channels, you can
do whatever you want.
But if you want some
guidance, Canary
is generally the first
devices to get any build.
It's a reference to the
canary in the coal mine idiom.
So if there's anything
wrong with the new build,
those canary devices will
tell you about it first.
Dev is generally where
developer devices sit.
Builds with lots of new
functionality, plenty of bugs,
but at least they boot up.
Beta is for your testers.
These are actual
users who are OK
getting some new functionality
by giving some feedback
about unreleased software.
And stable is where the
bulk of your users lives.
These builds are heavily tested
and everything should work.
Finally, custom is
whatever you want it to be.
In our developer previews,
we got lots of feedback
that people wanted
lots of channels
to divide up their device
population in different ways.
So we created custom
channels for them.
All right, so now that
you have these channels,
how do you get your
devices onto these channels
in the first place?
Devices default to
the stable channel.
But if you want to
change the channel,
you can set it via the
API, or connect your device
and flash your ADB
as shown up here.
One thing to keep in mind.
Remember how Amy
talked about release
versus development images.
You can flash a device
to a new channel
if it's running a
development image.
But if you're running
a public release image,
flashing and ADB are blocked.
So you can't change
the channel either.
We do this to prevent
end users from running
unwanted or malicious
code on your devices.
OK.
So now that you've
assigned the channels,
you can push updates to them.
You take the builds
that we created earlier,
create updates from
them, and then get
them delivered
onto your devices.
Updates are basically builds
with new features, bug fixes
or changes.
Pushing them to these
devices is called an OTA
or an over the air update.
Devices download these updates
and load them into B partition.
Once they reboot, it boots
into that B partition.
However, if there
is a problem, it
reverts back to the A partition.
I love this.
Because it means it
updates feel instant,
but they're also
fault tolerant too.
And everyone on Android Things
gets to take advantage of this.
One option for OTAs is
called fractional updates.
Rather than push an update
to 100% on your channel,
you can roll it
out gradually, just
to make sure if
something bad happens,
you're not affecting all
your users at the same time.
We highly recommend
using fractional updates
to de-risk your OTA approach.
Like I said earlier, nearly
all of this technology
is using the same
infrastructure that we
use every day to update millions
of devices in the field--
stuff like AB updates, delta
updates, fractional updates.
These are all difficult things
to get right but crucially
important if you want reliable
updates for your devices
worldwide.
AMY JANG: So like
Adam mentioned,
Android Things devices follow
the same OTA architecture
that Google uses, so you can
be confident that it will work.
But you might be
wondering, how does the OTA
work underneath the hood?
It's pretty simple flow.
When you specify
through Android Things
console, we update the OTA
server to hold information
about your product and
your update channel.
And the device will
report to the OTA server
with its build information
every five hour interval.
Then the OTA server will let
the devices know that you
have an update to pick it up.
Devices download and
install the new updated
build into the inactive AB
partition that we talked about.
Users will still be able
to use their devices
during this process.
Using Update Manager API,
you can have full control
over the update policy,
such as how often
do you want your devices to
ping for the update check,
and also customize device
behavior by listening
to update events.
So let's walk through an
example of a normal update
sequence, [INAUDIBLE] events
occurring inside the device,
and the following update
status events that are
posted to that app listener.
Update engine will
check OTA to the server,
and then OTA will let the update
engine client know that there
is a new update to pick it up.
And it will start
downloading the update.
As you can see in
this flow diagram,
the corresponding update events
are posted to app listener.
And that's your app.
Depending on the policy
you set, your app
can trigger reboot
of the device when
you think it's appropriate.
When the device
boots up, it will
start with the a new partition
where the update is written to.
Upon reboot, it checks
for update again.
And because it's
already updated,
it sits back at the idle
state until the next update
check happens.
So this is how you will use
the API to set the policy.
You can grab to update
manager instance
and set the policy you'll like.
Using apply only
policy, Update Manager
will download and
install the update
whenever a new
update is available.
And you can change
the update interval
frequency using this API--
say two days for example.
But say you want to
control the whole flow.
Then you can use the
check only policy
to listen to all update events
and control the whole update
process.
When you receive the
update available status,
you can decide whether it's a
good time to start the download
and install.
And when you think
it is a good time,
you can trigger the
perform update now
method to trigger it.
And when complete, you will
get the updated needs reboot
status.
And also, when you
think it's a good time,
you can trigger the
devices to reboot.
And it's all again
under your control.
It's very possible
that your devices
will require a zero day update.
When a customer buys a
product after some shelf time,
you might have already
upgraded your new software
to the next coolest thing.
And you want them to
start with that, right?
You don't want users to
download several gigabytes
of the new software before they
can start using your product.
Delta updates mean this payload
update is as small as possible.
Basically, based on your
factory image options,
and your previous OTA pushes,
Android Things console
will take care for you
and automatically generate
delta payloads
between the builds,
so devices can then receive
the smaller payload packets
between their current build
and your new coolest thing.
Imagine that your friend was
unwrapping a Christmas present.
And they had to wait 20 minutes
to download the latest version.
What a terrible
experience, right?
With delta updates,
its so much better.
ADAM RODRIGUEZ:
At this point, we
should probably
spend a little bit
of time talking about security.
As XKCD so elegantly points
out, you don't simply
build a secure device.
Having secure IoT means
constantly maintaining
and updating and looking
for vulnerabilities,
pushing changes throughout
the lifetime of your product.
We've talked quite a bit about
how Android Things is great
when you want to make
a lot of something.
But when you make
a lot of something,
do you really want to be
responsible for pushing
new updates throughout the
lifetime of that product?
Amy and I have an awesome
laundry robot now.
But maybe in a few years, we
go on to do something else.
Maybe we get different jobs.
And then what?
When we hear about
a new vulnerability,
do we research kernel
and library fixes?
Maybe we get back together
with all of our engineers
and then compile a new build
and push it to our users?
No.
That's not what happens.
In reality, these
orphaned devices,
they live on, connected to
the internet, perhaps unused,
but really vulnerable.
Thankfully, with Android Things,
we have a solution for this--
the auto update flag.
Because of our SoM strategy,
Google can confidently
push security fixes to all
IoT devices running that SoM,
be it a laundry folding
robot or a web cam.
Simply flip this
flag on your channel
and all your devices will
get regular security updates
from Google with zero
involvement from you.
It's important to
note-- you aren't
required to flip this flag.
If you don't enable
auto updates,
Google will still offer
up the security fixes,
but you can choose how and when
you want to implement them.
It's up to you.
Let Google manage your
updates or control
when they roll out yourself.
Let's talk a little bit about
how Android Things updates
and versioning works.
Major versions on
Android Things roughly
correspond to dessert
releases in normal Android.
These are large releases
supported for the long term
and represent Android
API framework changes.
The auto update flag
on their channel
does not update
across major versions.
So if you start on
major version 1,
even when major
version 2 is released,
you'll continue to get security
updates based on major version
1 if you so choose.
The second number is
the minor version.
These are comparatively
low risk updates.
They don't have any Android
API framework changes,
but they do have Android
Things API additions.
If you flip the
auto update flag,
you can expect to get updates
across new major versions.
So if you start on 1.2, when the
next minor version rolls out,
you will migrate to 1.3.
The last number is
a security update.
You can expect these to land
approximately every month.
There are no API changes.
And these updates definitely
increment with the auto update
flag on.
While major versions updates
are optional, in exchange
for getting free
updates through Google,
we do expect you to
update your versions
across each minor version
and security patch.
But how you do it is up to you.
You can either flip
the auto update flag,
or push the updates yourself.
It's our goal to make Android
Things the easiest and most
secure IoT platform out
there-- easiest to build,
and most secure and up
to date over the lifetime
of your product.
So how does this work across
SoMs and major versions
and years?
Each SoM is supported by Google
for a minimum of three years
from the time it was
first made available
on every available
major version.
So if you were to
buy the IMX8 SoM
and start building
on a major version 1,
you can expect updates
for the next three years,
all while remaining
on major version 1.
You don't have to
update a major version
2 to get the full support time.
Of course, we realize
that a lot of devices
will need much longer support
than those three years.
So if your SoM
supports it, you can
update to the next major
version and get a longer support
window.
You of course are always
able to push your own updates
for your devices for
their entire lifetime.
And finally, if you're looking
for an even longer support
time, come talk to us about some
options for extended support.
AMY JANG: All right.
So we've pushed our updates.
Our robots can now fold socks.
The last thing to
do is step back
and monitor how our robots
are doing in the field.
You probably want to check
out how many users are there.
Are they using my
devices every day?
Are they getting the
updates I just pushed?
Or how are my US robots doing
compared to the ones in Korea?
Android Things
console provides you
an end to end solution all
the way to device analytics.
With daily activation
and active graph,
you can monitor how your devices
are doing across your product.
You can use time range and
filter to do deeper analysis.
You can filter devices
by IP countries,
build IDs and update
channels and so on.
Within an hour after you
push OTA through console,
you can come to
this monitor screen
to see how your updates are
going, if there are any errors,
and what stage are
your devices at.
And the granularity that we
provide is up to every minute.
You can monitor various update
events, such as update checks,
various download status events,
and finally, the reboot event,
which tells the device has
rebooted to the new partition.
These events that you see here,
mapped to the status events
you saw in the Update
Manager API earlier.
And if there were any
errors with the update,
you can monitor the
update error graph
and drill down to
the update error
codes to see what's going on.
This is awesome because
right after I push my OTA,
I can watch this graph and see
if my devices are doing well--
if the release that I
pushed went off smoothly.
ADAM RODRIGUEZ: OK.
So we just walked you through
how to update your production
devices in the field.
But let's recap really quickly
about why you should care.
It's our goal to make IoT easy
and secure with Android Things.
We put a ton of work into
this so you don't have to.
We want you to focus on
the stuff that matters--
your hardware and
software, the thing
that differentiates
your product.
And then feel free to lean on us
for firmware, security patches
and update infrastructure.
By using Android Things, you
can to hire regular Android
developers, and use familiar
tools like Kotlin and Android
Studio.
You get to take advantage
of the same technology
that we use to update
millions of devices
in the field every day.
You get delta updates,
fractional updates,
AB partitions and
enhanced monitoring.
Can you imagine building
all of this yourself?
I'm sure you could.
But something tells me you'd
much rather be developing
new features and functionality
than reinventing an update
infrastructure.
There's also the crucial
piece of security updates
from Google.
It's an ideal way to ensure
that your products stay
secure with zero
involvement from you
for years down the road.
In the end we
really want to make
it easy to build secure,
update-able IoT, because we
think there's so much
opportunity for new products
and ideas in this space.
AMY JANG: And with that,
we want to say thank you
for attending our talk on
how to update production
devices in the field with
Android Things console.
Like we said before, there
are many options out there
for IoT, which OS and
hardware you may choose.
But if you're comfortable
writing Android code,
Android Things makes it super
easy for you to get started.
If you plan to build
and sell many devices,
and if you care about security,
as you should, and you want
an easy management of
your production devices,
Android Things will be a
great solution for you.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]